bonsoir thomas pourquoi julian assange
est utile sous la menace d'une
extradition soudainement et bien parce
que la justice britannique a autorisé
washington à faire appel de sa décision
en date du 4 janvier dernier on rappelle
que la justice britannique s'était
prononcé contre l'extradition de julian
assange en invoquant notamment les
problèmes de santé de du journaliste
lanceur d' alerte alors l'appel a été
acceptée mais il serait selon les
entourages et selon les informations de
wikileaks limiter à des aspects
techniques
on a pour le moment pas tellement de
détails sur la procédure ni sur une
éventuelle date pour une audience
écoutez la réaction du rédacteur en chef
de wikileaks
kraft et des services
cette décision intervient seulement une
semaine après qu'il a été révélé que
l'acte d'accusation contre julian était
sans fondement le témoin clé a rétracté
son témoignage est dit que le témoignage
qui a été reconnue par le juge
britannique à plusieurs reprises repose
sur une allégation véridique qui n'est
pas entièrement vrai c'est une
machination
les américains le savent mais reste
campé sur leurs positions
cet appel est une tentative désespérée
de retarder l'inévitable l'inévitable et
la libération de julian assange
s'il n'obtient pas sa liberté
ce sera un coup énorme porté à notre
société mais c'est comme si on le passé
sous silence
cela doit donc se terminer et je sens qu
au fond de moi cela arrivera bientôt un
thomas quelle conséquence à cette
décision sur son avenir
alors vous avez entendu l'optimisme du
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks mais
force est de constater que julian
assange va rester en prison dans cette
prison de haute sécurité de belmarsh au
royaume uni au moins jusqu'à cette
nouvelle audience a priori sauf
évolution dans cette affaire cette
prison de haute sécurité où les
conditions des tensions sont
intolérables ce sont les mots de
l'épousé de la compagne pardon de julian
assange d'ailleurs sa compagne a réagit
également à cette décision de la justice
britannique vous propose là encore de
l'écouter si l'administration byden
maintien vraiment à respecter l'état de
droit
le premier amendement et la liberté de
la presse dans le monde la seule chose
qu'elle puisse faire est d'abandonner
cette affaire cette affaire il attaque
la plus vicieuse de l'histoire contre la
liberté de la présente note alors vous
avez entendu la compagne de julian
assange en appel à la nouvelle
administration byden il y avait eu
quelques espoirs assez mince finalement
lorsque joe biden est arrivé au pouvoir
avec beaucoup d'appels pense par exemple
à l'appel de genève pour justement
encourager la nouvelle administration de
la maison blanche a abandonné les
poursuites contre julian assange
mais il faut dire qu'il n'y a pas
véritablement de changement en témoigne
également le lan interview dont tony
blinken le secrétaire d'état américain
qui était en france ils étaient arrivés
par nos confrères de brut
justement sur le sort de julian assange
il avait plutôt au botté en touche on
sent que il y a un peu de c'est un peu
compliqué de répondre pour la justice
pour les autorités américaines mais qui
compte véritablement continuer à
demander l'extradition de julian assange
on rappelle que les charges contre le
lanceur d'alert sont sous le coude dans
le cadre de l'espionage act et qu'il
encoure si toutes les charges sont
retenues contre lui jusqu'à 175 ans
d'emprisonnement ici aux etats unis
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington